rip my drip we haven't done that for a
while
uh this guy is chin here today is chin
here
oh damn he'll be back tomorrow though
they always come back this is uh and he
he wrote this this is
chris chaos420 he's a teacher assistant
at
elementary school for eight years he's
vaping quote unquote
cbd for stress occasionally throughout
the day and he has a podcast called the
friday podcast
you uh friday podcast used to be a
rapper but now has
but has been recording new songs he's a
single dad 31 years old with a 12 year
old
munches on the school lunch and
breakfast meals gets to kick it with
pre-k to fifth grade kids and gets to
talk about marvel
pokemon dragon ball z and other dope
stuff always keeping it rated g at work
except when i'm flirting with another
teacher and no kids are around oh
damn daddy he wants to rip his drip yeah
who knows what he signed up for he looks
like he looks like he sweats when he
watched nickelodeon
[Laughter]
probably he looks like he looks like the
uh
he looks like the high school he looks
like the last boss you have to fight at
in and out burger
he looks like he's about to get fired
yeah
it looks like when the school sees this
he's going to be out of a job
it looks like he should be driving for
uber [ __ ] 55 year olds
what do you say nick just that's not a
bad gig if you can get it ubering 55
year olds
it's not a bad gig
um bro this guy reminds me of his dude
mr vliet bro that went
went to my school he was a spanish
teacher
and he would have no idea what was going
on all year and then at the end of the
year you literally if you brought in
like anything that was mexican a spanish
casserole
a mexican friend a pitcher of a mexican
uh
you he'd give you 70 000 bonus points
he'd be like
oh you brought in two taquitos you got
20 000
bonus points and uh one of my best
friends saw him in the
bathroom during class during uh school
one day
and my my buddy was getting a d and he
[ __ ] threatened him right there at
the urinal and he goes if you [ __ ]
give me a d i'm gonna
i'm gonna rat you out i'm gonna tell
everybody what you're doing with your
million bonus points
for casseroles like that's insane and
the guy gave him a freaking [ __ ] oh
damn
well he sounds like he's also gonna lose
his job if he's still there
but this guy man yeah look i think if
you're non-practic if you're not
pedophiling and you're doing
regular and you're being an adult man i
respect that a lot of people can't be
around kids and not be a pedophile
yeah facts also if you got if you're
around kids that long you got to get
high so i'm not mad at this dude
sneaking up into the janitor's closet
smoking a little
reefer during his off time during fifth
period getting high with the other
teachers
i'm not mad at it ramming up bro do your
thing man do your thing especially if
you're hollering at those other bait
dude there's nothing sexier i don't
think than hooking up with the tv oh
preach like when that when those
scandals come out that this hot teacher
hooked up with
two students at the same time where the
[ __ ] was this happening when i was in
school
my teachers looked like [ __ ] yeah that
was a problem
my teachers looked like warlocks didn't
have a chance with us
[Laughter]
i'm sure one of them had a chance with
you who was the one that had a chance
now probably
probably mr decker
our spanish five teacher and she dated
uh a senior for like
and i was in love with her actually and
then i found out after
that she was only 24. she was only like
26 or something but yeah they
they dated all throughout his senior
year and like all the kids knew but
somehow the school didn't find and then
they continued the day after
and uh when i found out about that it
broke my heart because it was like i was
in freshman i was like i could have had
a chance what a real love story you
think they're still together
i don't think they are we should have
them calling
yeah i almost said her name yeah she
probably got fired as well
i think she dude i'll tell you straight
up miss garafola i think was our lady's
name she taught matthew or something i
don't even know
right when i got into her class i was so
freaking just
erect the whole time i don't know what
she was teaching i don't know she was
teaching math i didn't know if she
worked at our school dude
all the blood would just run to
different ends of my body dude
and she wore like perfume or cologne or
something it was good
[Music]